after the American kind of like gaming
phase that you went through in YouTube
what what came after that uh did lots of
indie games
um you know like everyone breaking it
was that so obviously breaking it as
much as possible oh yeah ideally like
lots of mods and stuff I I like kind of
what everyone was doing at that point
like that was the biggest thing was like
the jacksepticeye's the even PewDiePie
at that point everyone was sort of just
doing Indie Games it was like obviously
people were successful in Minecraft
could do whatever but I still think the
biggest games at the time were
definitely like playing random games
then I kind of started doing reactions
for a bit like I just would look at
Reddit and be like
yeah I mean at that point I was doing
like 150 200k video that's not bad did
that for a couple years but the issue
was it was good then at apocalypse
happens and the problem is when you're
saying all the naughty words because
you're Australian
stop it stopped making money so
you're you're having to they're applying
American ad standards on yeah yeah UK
and Australia who notoriously swear a
lot more than the Americans the c word
is so easy to say it's not even I didn't
even say a c words just because the fact
that like you know how some people say
like um yeah like that's [__] for me I
say [__] um as well but it's with
[__] in there as well yeah it's like a
sandwich of it so it meant that like
every third word in the video was just
[__]
and especially the reactions and like I
I was probably a bit edgy at the time
where I'd show clips of like dumb [__]
happening yeah no one dying
no so I did the Reddit 50 50 videos
but like you could kind of probably
still anyway yeah like you could maybe
see some [__] [__] I don't know but I
deleted this
um but yeah I feel like
I just 2016 and pray YouTube was such a
different place so I was still kind of
existing like that yeah the whole back
catalog and then at apocalypse happens
so somehow like fortnite family friendly
yeah you know it's especially the first
year of fortnite still swear a little
bit but I definitely tried to be a
little bit more intelligent with how did
you get like a lot of parents you mean
like you've got to stop swearing oh all
the time no my favorite one it's my big
it's the such it's not even that much of
a swear word but my favorite one is
um it was Peak covered so like
viewership was crazy it was the biggest
Fortnight event at the time I think I
had like 900k viewers because no one
could get in the game right I was doing
a live stream for the events was this on
YouTube yeah well I I was the number one
uh for that day like when everyone was
streaming I happen to be the number one
Stream So when the servers went down and
only so many people were in the game
yeah everyone just flooded to YouTube so
all right it was just like crazy but the
point is I I was saying there was like a
delay in the event for some reason and I
was like this event gave me blue balls
it was the most
thing I was watching this with my nine
year old daughter now I have to explain
to my nine-year-old daughter what blue
balls are and I'm just like why why do
you have to explain
well you don't no one asked you explain
that
I was probably saying [__] [__] and
stuff before it so like do your due
diligence as a parent to know what your
kids are watching and whether they
should be allowed to watch me that's all
I'm saying yeah the moment you hear that
Australian accent you should be on
higher work yeah yeah yeah it's just
like that doesn't seem like my problem I
gotta ask because like you know when you
have your normal viewers on a live
stream you know you don't really bat an
eye at it because you're so used to
having this kind of audience when it was
getting up to like when you had like 900
000 you're starting to get like a little
a little nervous you're like oh God this
is it was there's a lot of people it's
definitely weird
but I think because it was a fortnight
event you know I knew they weren't like
it wasn't so much about me it was kind
of like oh yeah
just show it off it's just not cool but
minimize that box of you in the corner
and shrink it and be like sure I
honestly could I could have been on mute
no one give a [__]
um I feel like once it goes past a
certain number I just don't think about
it that's true yeah like it'd be a lot
more stressful when you first started
and you get 10 viewers yeah when you go
from like
10K concurrents to 50K just it's like
yeah obviously you appreciate it was
like this you're not actually changing
what you're doing yeah yeah have you
tried to I guess like more well not so
much sensor but be more self-conscious
about you know like swearing and just
being Aussie oh I still but more
strategically like I'll say it when it's
necessary
I was talking to uh Mr Beast about a
watch like a couple years ago and he's
like you don't have to swear to be funny
and I was like because he said he used
to be a little bit more edgy back in the
day yeah yeah yeah
and he obviously cleaned himself up a
lot he's talking to me about it because
I was so stressed that my ad rates were
so bad yeah yeah and he's like look I've
got mine to this point from this point
like here's what you got to do and he's
just like you don't have to swear to be
funny I'm like
but so that goes against every
Australian like yeah yeah it's such a
fun word to say yeah
but yeah so I sort of toned it back and
I was like okay
I'll just be more strategic so if like
the [__] really serves the video yeah it
really serves what I'm saying yeah then
I say it but now like you've got to just
be more careful in general yeah because
I do like scripted videos and I also
noticed like the big dip and like ad
Revenue when whenever like my older
videos had much more swearing in it so
every time like I script a video now if
I use like a swear word I'm like can I
can I replace this word and it still hit
the same yeah the problem is though 90
of the time I'm just like I need the
[__] there man yeah
I [__] need it
yeah I remember we did a woody ruin our
address it's fine yeah
we're in Australia we kind of know when
we're in Australia yeah it's fun yeah
yeah the ad rates are going to go down
it was one of like and probably
I guess in a lot of ways when you're
scripting is probably not as much of an
issue but I did find it stressed me out
so much more and made it so much more
like harder to record yeah because I was
constantly thinking about what I was
saying for the first time ever yeah
there was everything else just always
just be even if like I think early on I
probably put on a little bit more of the
I was a bit louder I was a bit more like
talking full-on yeah but still
everything I was saying was kind of just
whatever just yes also I I like I can
never know sometimes what counts as like
a swear word for like the American
audience or like the American
corporations because I remember we
wanted a panel uh I think it was just me
and Joey that did a panel in uh La uh
and it was like a very very big panel
and we had to like sign a contract being
like you cannot swear
on stage you cannot swear and I'm like
ma'am I understand I will be I will only
speak the queen's English for this panel
and within like the first five minutes I
say God damn it or something oh really
and I I didn't know that counted as a
sweat would never think about it yeah
yeah I just said God damn it and then
they muted my mic because they were like
we said no swearing and I was like what
did I say and they were like you took
the you took the lord's name in vain
yeah that is a swear word if it's not a
gosh darn it yeah it's not on here and I
was like I could not believe it I've
recorded with some people that don't
like you saying like oh yeah God damn it
or anything they don't like you saying
God in any way which is fair enough I
guess that I'll respect that yeah yeah
it is such a so foreign to me for that
to be very insulting so yeah so like you
said that like that when the apocalypse
happened you were like affected quite
heavily like at to what degree did it
affect you because it's like I feel
especially you know for someone like an
Australian Creator where it's like so
easy to just say [__] and like yeah all
the other words like how like what
percentage of your channel just got
[__] over
um I mean so every video is demonetized
and it was for like
18 months until I started fortnite it
was actually like now if I look back a
lot of them got greened again but yeah
right how many videos are we talking
like I was I was doing like I was doing
daily I posted roughly at that point it
was like every video
um and obviously those people so far
worse off because like I was able to
move back with my parents and stuff and
I was probably still earning like
in a month or so yeah I'm sitting here
to move back in with your parents yeah
well I lived in Sydney it's just like I
was paying like 600 bucks a week rent or
something like that it's like
so I ended up like having someone else
move in to pay the rent and then I just
went back to my parents oh my God and so
like but it's more of the fact that like
yeah I'm still probably doing like four
or five k a month on revenue or
something but like
it was like but it wasn't adding up for
the views you were getting right and
that might have been Australian dollars
too so that was like I don't know this
like two three k yeah
it's like I had enough to live but it's
like then there's no savings and stuff
and it's like you're right on that edge
of like this is obviously enough to live
that's like especially at that point in
my life this is enough to live yeah I
have a slight dip in views yeah yeah
it's like because it's dangerous yeah
it's like okay then I'm actually got
like so that's like it was more of the
anxiety of being on the edge of that
right
um and granted bless my audience they
were very supportive at the time because
I was very transparent about I was like
and it was just like you know obviously
plenty of creators also still work and
do YouTube at the same time respect that
massively but it's like once you break
out like once I left the job site go it
was just like it's a scary thing is like
no this is not gonna last forever this
could disappear like if I have one
little dip I'm just it's just done yeah
yeah yeah and yeah I know massively
privileged too that like my parents
would still house me you know a lot of
people obviously don't have that either
so my situation was nowhere near as bad
as it could be but yeah it just created
so much unnecessary stress I think like
I'll say as soon as they started you
could like review the videos yeah that's
when it got back up to like four or five
k a month right right because like some
of them would go back to being green at
some point yeah yeah yeah so like we
write a lot of YouTubers who kind of
just like fell into the occupation like
out of I guess like accidents because
they never I guess they never thought
that this would be a job but it sounds
like you got into this with the
expectation that you're like I want to
make this my job I want this to be my
career like what when did you start to
realize okay I can actually make this a
thing honestly like that like first
three months on the gaming channel I was
like yeah shit's easy
I'm actually [__] amazing
um no I mean I have massive imposter
syndrome so like the entire time bro so
everyone yeah every YouTube yeah yeah
yeah I was like this is this is going
away it's like I'm actually making [__]
videos why is anyone watching this it's
all Bots or something but I was like
well I'm not gonna quit where it's
working I don't know yeah
um
bad I don't know always never felt valid
are you ever going to go back to the
construction routes where you just start
smashing and [__]
um
we should revisit it yeah yeah yeah that
sounds like a little ten year period
yeah yeah yeah
if I can get like a proper team to do
the proper slow-mo like I am the slo-mo
guys like I do know Gavin quite well
maybe get him over here buddy yeah feel
me smashing some with an excavator
um I mean yeah it'd be fun I've I have
had something written down for ages to
remake my first videos right that'd be
great free videos yeah I just don't like
leaving the house I don't like touching
them so thank you for coming out I just
feel like real world production
intimidates me a lot I know how to like
build something out in the gaming space
or even when I did Real World stuff it
was always a vlog like this bless
everyone all the everyone doing the
production here yeah it's stressing me
are you building a studio now was that
sorry aren't you building a studio we
are we are but still it's mostly just
gonna be me sitting at a desk there
they've just got like like offices
around it just stay out yeah yeah and
like I I mean I might build off like a
lot of what locky's doing and his
experience and even work with the people
here yeah knowing them quite well now I
might do some real world things you
might see me uh my favorite ones it's
like a slasher so it's like a big he put
on a Bobcat you can tilt it up you can
throw things into it so imagine throwing
things in a giant lawnmower blade I push
that